le monde il est attaqué par chronique
sur l'échiquier est attaqué par l'unedic
physiquement par des ondes sonores
nuisances c'est vrai et oui très très
difficile de gérer tous ces combats en
menant pour garry kasparov
c'est incroyable incroyable ce que
trouvent kramnik te retrouver sa ville
voit toi ça dépend canton qui si j'avais
joué contre 1 2200 je ressens de
retrouver ces jeux je compte caspar où
j'aurais fait nul oui assez vite
et oui comme quoi ça dépend vraiment de
qui on a en face ses traits
psychologiques les échecs cramique le
roi des caisses par envoyer c'est une
chasse aux rois café kramnik il est en
train
mais quand on a pas le choix la menace
et on prend 1,7 il peut prendre car il
prend la scène peut-être les points 5
pour kasparov
ouais
peu probable très peu probable
c'est sa seule chance face aux menaces
de perdre rapidement stéphanois
quels points 5 je ne sais pas je ne
pense pas je vois pas de réputation
immédiate mais il doit y en avoir une
incroyable ce qu'on trouvait kramix est
fou complètement fou les pièces de
kasparov ce gène
c'est complètement incroyable
garry kasparov mal autant mal à la
position je pense que kasparov va nous
surprendre avec son prochain coup ça me
paraît très probable
en fait je pense voilà ce qui fait la
différence pour l'instant notre
chronique et les autres ses adversaires
que kasparov a eu c'est que kramnik n'a
absolument pas peur de kasparov la
preuve c'est qu'il réfléchit dans ce
genre d'opposition qui ont l'air
complètement égal il réfléchit il
cherche la chance et la trouve c'est
fini des parties loi ancienne partie
d'échecs où les joueurs faisait des nuls
facile voilà des joueurs de la deûle à
32 kramnik c'est fini faut jouer
jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas de rendement
d'après et les échecs devienne un vrai
sport là ça devient du beau spectacle
d'après un vrai sport puisqu'il faut il
faut lutter jusqu'au bout basque et sur
ses chroniques quand il a eu les blancs
pour l'instant nous a régalés à camper
avec une victoire dans la première une
nulle combative extrêmement combatif
dans la deuxième est celle là qui est
également superbe alors que kasparov
avec les plantes ne fait pas grand chose
puisque travnik neutralisent simplement
ouais mais la chronique a eu très chaud
à noter que c'était très chaud pour
vladimir kramnik superbe gestion des
matches pour la vrai mais ça se joue à
peu de chose gagner nos matchs déchets
qui va déjà avoir peur un moment il
faisait pas trop le malin plaisir c'est
incroyable incroyable que maintenant il
ne fait beaucoup plus c'est incroyable
donc les points sans que stéphane je
pense que sa peur tout de suite après
tour pour acheter il faut dire que ses
parents s'est affaiblie tout seul il est
joué psy si le jouet j'ai bien été
obligé il avait déjà une pression
mauvaise question fabriqués c 17 a été
n'avait peut-être déjà plus de solutions
c'est à dire au moment où nous étions en
train de dire chronique foutu eh bien
peut-être que kasparov était déjà foutu
mais c'est ça la magie avec ses joueurs
c'est qu'on ne peut pas leur reprocher
un seul coup
il n'y a pas un seul coup qu'on puisse
leur reprocher leur critique et ça se
joue à vous cette fatwa rien ça se joue
à peu il ya que ces joueurs là qui
comprennent les échecs ça se joue à
quelques phrases telles près ouais que
ces jours-là qui comprennent le jeu tel
qu'ils le pratiquent
c'est tout bonnement incroyable et ça
prouve encore une fois que l'ordinateur
mais en réfléchissant
alors attention ce n'est pas dit blue
ici c'est quand même ce n'est pas dit
bleu bonne là dans les cordes biarritz
très jolie clan il trouve pas de
solution cast on ne les trouve pas ça
soit n'y a pas de choix il faut shooter
au sec
non il y avait lieu sarkozy à mettre en
scène sa paire le cas il ya maintenant
il ya la tour emprise au sol ou
cavignaux 5 bref tous les coups sont
mauvais de toute façon qu'est ce qui se
passe sur toro 5 damas sept cavaliers 18
qui est d'éviter les je crois stéphane
qui lie à damette 8 s'est assuré des
mythes comme intéressante en voyant ce
qui se passe donc je pense qu'on va
réfuté facilement mais on va refaire un
bilan position avec l'idée de répéter
les coups encore une fois voilà donc
tour cinq sets une possibilité toujours
on envisage donc la dame f7 à mes
fenêtres et sur cavaliers en début
d'année des huit il doit y avoir une
réputation très rapide voilà pour 3,7
il ya beaucoup trop miné zon s'était
faite en trois sets à wimbledon un f6
prend la tour voile ainsi le rythme tout
reproche cette dame 3 est obligatoire
pour l'instant ici c'est à dire la tour
et la position noir il n'y a plus qu'une
grosse poubelle puisque le pion g5 sera
encore prise à la fin c'est plus
inquiétant prises le pion c5 est passé
même si philippe s'effondre une cavale
ici c'est terminé c'est horrible ce
n'est pas une solution
il n'y a pas de solution nous
remonterons la position dans laquelle il
est en train de se débattre
travnik je vais demander à mes questions
qu'ils aillent à quoi il ya trois
copains c'est faire nul il ya trop qu il
pensait faire mieux non mais si en plus
ils avaient l'air de dire au moc est
atteindre 11 nuls en fait comique c'est
un véritable acteur quand même parce que
rien ne pouvait prédire en voyant son
visage au fait qu'il ait vu ce qui s'est
passé incroyable c'est incroyable qu'à
trouver krainik
c'est complètement hallucinant alors
qu'il ne reste que 20 minutes à kasparov
et 27 à crâne d'oeuf pour jouer les 13
prochain prouve que krainik a posé
d'énormes problèmes kasparov pour jouer
presque 20 minutes
kasparov avec 14 coups à jouer ça peut
faire une différence kasparov 14 coups
et kramnik 13 kg lucas joué le coup
dames 17
c'est incroyable vous êtes en train
d'assister actuellement à peut-être très
probablement la deuxième victoire de
valmer kramix qui serait tout bonnement
exceptionnel à ramlila jouer il ajoute
euro 5 et où il n'avait pas le choix
kasparov tour 5 il ya des familles qui
va jouer dans mes fils est tout de suite
c'est un peu nous avons avec une grosse
poubelle ladignac ravel cette e-menace
croire est loin de cette e-menace pour
preuve cette limite tenant dans ses
mains ce reproche est sa menace que sa
menace quelque chose d'à f 7
d'ailleurs ça venait savez fuites ces
femmes tout est là mais fuite peut-être
peut-être d'autres choses n'ont pas bien
mais qu'est ce que ces menaces en fait
de 9,7 très intéressante
c'est très intéressant de savoir ce que
me lasse coude à 9,7 d'un logiciel qui
n'a pas de coût pour le moment tout
simplement ça doit être ça car il prend
à 5 par exemple
joli coup n'avait peut-être que noir
sont en outre stefan mais si ça alors ça
on va puisque c'est un besoin alors
profitons-en alors ça c'est génial du
besoin après d'aleph 7 garry kasparov
secret au grand que ça veut dire que
chaque coup qu'il jouait mauvais mais il
n'y a pas de choix et de jouer un coup
et il est forcément mais alors regardons
d'ailleurs cette variante très
instructive proposé par l'ordinateur sur
b4 coût neutre moyens complètement
neutre et bien et bien rouages de nom si
proche d'eux et la baroche de il ya plus
de coups mais en wav de un autre
avantage c'est que ces menaces g4 à huy
g4 et si la dame prend il ya tout
reprendre cette mare à la tête alors que
si on faisait gk tout de suite y avait
un échec au roi voilà c'est ça donc
c'est un coup profil amirouche 2 était
un coup extrêmement fort puisque g4 est
une menace horrible
donc pareil sur cavaliers princiens qui
enrage 2 alors sur quels points 5
il ya plus violent il ya tours 37
puisque le cavalier de le défendre et
plus la tour sexualité défendre et cette
tour par exemple après calais prendre
alors là bas alors évidemment ouvrage 2
500 visage aussi mais pourquoi je sais
très fort on va jouer à leur fort aussi
mettons qu'on achète c'est plus direct
plus direct mais rôle de héros le
leinster a noté qu'il recommande heroes
un jeu mais si ça c'est pas mal non plus
cette position-là moi elle est
probablement gagnante
wyplay matériel voiture vaut mieux être
sûr quand ces gagnants la menace ces
dames à schwyz celui de fonds prend g5
avec un horaire beaucoup de possibilités
encore pour la lumière non ici il faut
quelque chose avec cette chronique je
pense qu'il va le faire pourrait
semblablement way la mecque saleh ben
oui y'a pas mieux il veut vérifier lui
est sûr mais il va le faire mais ne pas
échanger des dames aussi peut pas
changer les dames anne on n'en serait
pas un nombre non pop blague quand on
voit un roi aussi faible qui sur terre
envisage s'échangent les dames peuple ça
il va jouer voilà on a joué il a eu
envie de jouer faut faire gaffe à ce
qu'il peut encore faire des gaffes
il peut encore se tromper vous le dire
mais la tendance enregistrée au camp nou
samedi c'est horrible d'un médecin
d'adrar wheeler ça y est le vilain seuil
et garry kasparov dans la nasse je suis
très curieux de voir la tête qu'il va
faire la menace c'est probablement
rouages deux rôles de et l'avait cas
d'un décès du marin une menace comme ça
et loi doit être un coup droit à
cramique attend kasparov
va t'il eut proposé nu kasparov dans un
écrin unique
non je ne pense pas ce signe alors il a
24 minutes à gravelines contre 20 à 40
places par of semble-t-il est foutu
c'est incroyable non royal il s'agit
bien d'eux ou dîner garry kasparov il
peut s'échapper de n'importe quelle
situation dans milan voit pas comment
ton 25
abella ton des cinq ses tournages
permettront aux states à permettons 3,7
à moins que grave kramnik joue 3h de nom
mais rouages de 6 à ne menacent plus g4
ses fans qui est sûr est un des cinq
échecs
ah oui si on élargit la tour s'est
enlevée il y aurait autour des 1 est
donc là pour prendre cette ton prince de
galles la tour avec avec une position
gagnante puisque le cas et c'est si
cette attaque est ainsi que le pion aux
4,1 millions puis voilà nommé on va
rencontrer ce qui se passe après tôt
pour acheter
c'est important c'est probablement la
suite de cette partie d'un projet est
obligé et là on prend la tour des cinq
qui n'est plus défendue par la dame
noire
on attaque donc le cas et c'est six mois
si ce cavalier par exemple prend le pion
à 5
on l'a déjà vu il ya dam des mythes
double attaque 1,8 à table cavaliers et
le pion et si c'est ça c'est une
catastrophe pour que ce sport puisque
quand on prend ainsi son propos si j'ai
cinq sens et ça veut rien dire c'est
horrible
kamal est proprement simple n'est donc
pas possible pour garry kasparov
ici il devra trouver un coup solide dans
cette mission peut-être le goût de ces
sept
c'est possible sur quoi on peut jouer
dans trois quatre et après camille prend
à 5 qui va sans doute arriver le fameux
coup qu'on attendait depuis le début f2f
4 1 me qui commence est très fort et il
va être l'estocade finale contre le roi
noir amusant un cavalier de kasparov qu
aux fraises
ah oui c'est vrai au frais et oui parce
que s'il est mort près gnafu prend avec
quatre échecs à laquelle la dame et ça
offre complètement la position ça
m'agace pions pranger scène suivi deux à
mach 4 échecs sa menace de 9,5 également
sa master projets s'inquiète à mach 4
c'est terminé
c'est horrible complètement horrible
est-ce que ou dini va y passer est dans
le c'est horrible ce qu en train de
faire kramnik kasparov
voilà la position radicale et loi ça va
être un tremblement de terre dans les
échecs kramnik va jouer pour point je
sais tu que va nettement mieux
il va probablement gagner et c'est là le
retournement de situation dans ce match
vraiment c'est incroyable les quatre
amies qui n'a pas gêné quand kasparov de
ma vie
depuis trois ans une hôtesse porsche n'a
pas battu chronique depuis 3000 ans mais
là il entraîne le m 2 0 en partie oui
alors si c'est non non mes skis c'est
l'occasion à le score café peter l'écho
contre khalifa sall a mis 3 0 en six
parties si horrible c'est vrai c'est un
plus il aurait pu gagner la quatrième
non c'est si le même qu'à deux c'est un
masque d'argile coréen potentiel le
classement elo de 3000 alors on peut
calculer ses performances très
simplement sitôt après 4,2 contre garry
kasparov il aurait une performance égale
il faut rajouter 100 points au
classement de kasparov
c'est à dire 2952 1952 performance
contre garry kasparov
c'est exceptionnel cette exceptionnelle
si horrible et dont il tomberait à
rattraper kasparov au classement elo ah
oui il faut le dire quand même bien des
questions vézina quand il pourrait
dépasser kasparov au classement elo et
il ne faut pas qu'ils se trompent les
dernières années qu'elle entraîne rougir
parce que là il sait y attention finir
attention une loi quand on va gagner
quand on est énorme on a toujours une
grosse tension surtout contre eux
kasparov c'est une partie qui vaut cher
qui vaut de l'argent c'est une partie
qui vaut cent mille peut-être 200 mille
dollars
je dirais plus stéphane puisque citera
nikbakhat par un fort match
eh bien oui non mais la partie et le
même paragraphe sans denner la
probabilité de gain du match
ah là là c'est un calcul auquel il
faudrait se livrer ces femmes ça doit
être énorme
est-ce que cram ni combien gagne un tram
ni quand marco impôts maintenant et mike
rann il gagne peut-être sans milou 208
dollars sur cette partie sur quelques
coups précis à jouer mais sans compter
la suite qu'il est championne du monde
c'est horrible ils sont à 20minutes ch
et indirects à strophes c'est exactement
ce qu'il doit faire s'il veut en fumée
vladimir kramnik dans cette situation
minutes à kramnik pour jouer douze coups
contre 19 minutes à kasparov normes et
l'acide position crâne michael fou en
plus influent contre un cavalier non
mais le roi de kasparov est très très
lundi le roi et reine en russie c'est
complètement c'est foutu cc clermont
foot us en décalant va jouer parce que
les ko debout là il faut qu'ils ont mis
là il le croit pas qu'à sport parce
qu'il ya trois coups de sa alors
attention puisque l'ordinateur aurait
trouvé mieux que tôt pour acheter
il s'agirait du coup b2b 4
incroyable non je ne sais pas il dit que
c'est plus fort et c'est possible
puisque quand on a trouvé un bon coup il
faut toujours rechercher un meilleur
c'est ce que fait chronique donc
vladimir kramnik en tout cas une chose
est sûre et bien maintenant on met deux
mais quatre nuls parce qu'ils adorent
échec - orange 2 et alors tu menaces
plus non parce que ça complique kramnik
c'est le gagner tranquillement avec la
finale de demain mais fou alors que la
cirest détour c'est compliqué non c'est
sacré l'influencé peut-être mise à
l'encan des possibilités je ne sais pas
finir mais si la toiture bouger faut
plonger des étrangers 5 qui règne là
pourquoi pas bougé et donc c'est pour ça
que vladimir kramnik réfléchi évidemment
il a vu tout reproche est évidemment ils
cherchent mieux suivant bien que je ne
suis pas sûr cavaliers prend on va jouer
alors envisageons b2b 4 c'est une
possibilité
ça voudrait dire simplement que les
noirs n'ont rien à faire dans cette
position ne peuvent rien faire admettant
que les noirs admettons que je comprenne
l'option cavaliers prend pions et bien
là incroyable
ces rouages de qui gagne et pourquoi
puisque on menace g2g cad et on ne voit
pas ce que peuvent faire les doigts pour
s'en prémunir
ah oui parce que ont-ils simplement son
échec confère un g2 et loi sur échec sur
dame sanquer shanxi
bonsoir 2005 échec qu'on joue j'ai trois
oui non mais si la menace g4 oui bien
sûr oui par exemple ainsi dit noir joue
à rien mais rallye es1 es3 on va dire à
tentant de revenir vers le roi dans ce
cas là en jour et g4g 4 la dame ne peut
pas prendre sinon c'est matt on achète
et sur échec il suffit de jouer en rage
et 2 pourquoi je crois plutôt stephen
ouvrage 3 senna rejoint roger devroe
chien moi j'ai un lien plus des chèques
aux jeunes des plus déchets voilà moi
j'aime être tranquille
voilà c'est terminé il ya encore de
shane williams attention dit la machine
aux attendes 6 puisque les noirs sont
obligés de donner la dame voilà donc
kramnik calcul probablement ça alors la
question qui nous vient à l'esprit
immédiatement c'est pourquoi pas jouer
rouages de tout de suite à la place de
b4 c'est une question qui a son intérêt
comme stéphane les rouages de tout de
suite qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien il
y aura ici lesquels des big three
d'élite avec des complications
apparemment alors non mais attention
attention attention on est dans sept
pays sur l'a64 amic de jouer on a vu
qu'il peut jouer ton courage 7 avec un
net avantage
on a vu qu'il peut jouer p4 avec un gros
avantage
on a vu qu'ils peugeot renault avec des
bonnes perspectives c'est pour ça qu'il
réfléchit il ne sait plus et crown et
ouais bien kasparov a trouvé un plan
huit minutes à cramique lelangue garry
kasparov c'est ça c'est je te laisse
plein de gains débrouille-toi vladimir
tu peux faire ce que tu veux ça gagne
mais il faut qu' il faut changer
d'alliance choisir un nom mais pas
choisir 18
qu'est ce qu'il faut qu'est ce qui
serait beau ça serait que technique
j'avais quatre ans à turin aux salaires
des tonga et loi encore une fois comment
ça ça a l'air d'être une gaffe ça a pas
l'air d'être forcément le plus efficace
c'est vrai
garry kasparov a l'air d'être forcé de
choquer et des beats alors évidemment si
c'est un cas forcé il va le jouer très
très vite
bon salaire tatung afro achats et loi ça
ressemble pas un bon coup il faut le
dire qu'est ce qui se passe sur ton
échec
il semblerait stéphane que ça ne menace
pas g4 mais non parce qu'ils auraient
tord échec et rouages de forcer et là
d'un échec
peut-être je ne comprends pas pourquoi
c'est notre page et caf alors regardons
quand même pour voir par exemple si b4
et bien pourquoi j'ai 4 n'est pas une
menace c'est une question qu'on peut se
poser comme les chroniques non stéphane
stéphane cette incroyable tour d un
temps d un échec
william meynard oui à perpignan h2 et
cavaliers des 4 un vrai scandale
que se passe-t-il c'est un sacrifice de
dom sinon mes chroniques un film mais
c'est encore la dame alors la lorelei
amat et bien il y accueille des f3 avec
nulle sur les 15 h un lien avec la tour
oh non il n'ya pas nul il n'ya pas nul
pourquoi l'euro s'échappe par où je ne
sais pas
moi j'ai trois pour gérer chèques
devraient s'y embrassent trois tours à
chaque échec tu ne s'échappe pas
pourquoi cramique à jouer ce coup qui a
l'air complètement bidon on ne sait pas
roche les sens on aurait aimé vallat
c'est pas possible est-ce que kramnik
normes attention attention stéphane
parce que la question
la charge est un peu long mais ce n'est
pas grave puisque nous allons revenir
dans la véritable position très vite
j'ai 5
petit rappel d'un machin qu'est chaque
point cette dame des sept tours dé cet
échec
brochet this tour à tour g73 grande dame
17 très bien joué et elle a perdu au
kram nick du toit cinq des sept tours
des 5
orange est là l'incroyable se produit au
large à 1 qui plonge kasparov dans une
réflexion écrit simplement parce que
cathcart n'avait pas envisagé ce coup
ils avaient envisagé tous les autres
pourquoi ce qu'on bizarre c'est très
très surprenant mais l'autre côté
peut-être oui mais en fait quand on peut
toujours jouer 37 et un grand tour la
tour bouge qui à tour bouge en cia échec
six taureaux d un échec
c'est embêtant quand même temps d un
échec non parce que la main du roi fou
projet de 5 à la mi mai qualité 4 non
mais faut quand j'ai senti une grosse
menace est fan a gagné des cats hamas
contrôle la dame ah oui donc tu voudrais
dire tour d un pur h2 et qu'elle ait
cédé 4 way essayons de voir cette
variante a key des huit je vais par
kasparov gagner des vies très vite
qu'avaient les 18
donc là ça oblige kramnik à jouer tours
et ça c'est plutôt bon pour nous on peut
pas un chèque ou bien d'années suit
également revient dans la variante qu'on
avait cité tout à l'heure
les crânes il voulait jouer c'est si ce
n'était pas clair
brach un coup curieux quand evans
vernant incroyable que je viens de voir
damas fuite serait un bon coup ici
puisque sur kallio 6 alors là aussi on
peut montrer l'échiquier c'est une
variante très important la position
qu'ils ont ce moment c'est la suivante
caspar vient de jouer qu'avec des vite
ils en mettent le cavalier là qui
attaquent donc un mythe tout en
l'adaptant innovants sur des fuites
sicav agneaux 6 il y à tour plonger 5
échec au roi
quand j'y suis couché double énorme
échec tout ça il faut prendre le faut
prendre la dame il a tous prendre nos
échecs chen fu une fois de plus avec le
futsal est là pour des 5es part du guide
at war 2 5i passe ces cui cui mais sur
en fait surnommer suite est tout
simplement rouages 5 probablement à
leroy s'échappe tout simplement stephen
je ne dirais pas ça c'est tout sauf
simple après brouage 5 il ya encore
plein de choses à faire
en tout cas c'est très très chaud autre
possibilité pour chronique c'est de
jouer tout simplement tort qu'on achète
de ce nom et empire ou achat c'était une
faute c'est pas grave il faut il faut
faire tourner en acheter sa famille par
les attentions à 16 minutes akram me
contre 16 à kasparov pour jouer on
secoue kramnik va-t-il rater kasparov
comme il l'a raté samedi et ça ça serait
un nouveau coup au moral
ils vont faire tout à fait comme
l'horrible non fonctionnement un peu
cramé ne se voit pas mais d'un autre
côté il vérifie tout puisque ce qui est
dommage maintenant c'est que de surtout
prend hc3 prendre tout d'emprunt des
culées or noir joue le roi ça fait échec
c'est vrai c'est vrai tout à fait ça
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour le moral de
chroniques et la kasparov pourrait
inspirer se défendre cette position
le courage un simple est imprécis pour
espérer se défendre mais c'est quand
même bien compromise stéphane il a
encore une poubelle garry kasparov
c'est sûr c'est clair parce que le
cahier d'éviter est attaquée ils s'en
sortent pas on ne s'en sort pas les
mains propres
voilà c'est une superbe partie vraiment
du grand spectacle aujourd'hui on est
vraiment gâtés et gâtés gâtés et oui là
on avait cru qu'on allait avoir une une
partie nulle après une chronique qui
était passé tout près de la
correctionnelle
il avait réussi à tirer la nuit mais
n'en kasparov qui pensaient que c'était
nul et qui semblait même dépité
finalement ne pas avoir gagné faisait
nul en dix ans beau mais tant pis c'est
nul mais non quand même tu dis mais n'en
attends c'est pas fini joue à saute
jouer c'est pas parce que tu m'a rappelé
que moi je les trappes et voilà
exactement
et ça c'est incroyable incroyable avril
son site font vivre au sein direct et
moi pour se rendre compte de l'émotion
parce que si on lui vont repenser après
des analyses sérieuses et plus à naples
au ramadan a plus rien à voir ça enlève
tout son sel c'est vrai ici c'est
vraiment ta fille laïla il a poussé
kasparov à la faute en jouant ce coût
aux achats fait qu'elle imite ce n'est
pas une faute quoi
non mais il essayait de classement juste
trompés tu vois essayant de vous fâchez
pas là bon là il ya les tours prend
l'intérieur et les allez allez allez
pas de bla y bla bla gulfstream humide à
stress chronique les pièces on avait
envie de jouer dans ma fuite il a envie
de garder les pièces autres alain avait
dans les fuites c'est l'horreur damas
fuite c'est pas mal la machine
recommande à 9,8 mais tout reprocher tu
sais pas un mirage 5 sur 2008 c'est
compliqué peut-être premier 4
à une vaguelette à la fuite là il est
parti quand j'aide à la fuite aussi non
parce que ce sont les la dame et la tour
son urne contenant votre envoi d'un
torrent j'espère quand j'arrête monza
corner ok ouf
ses vents du taur point je t'aime
tellement elle en est sûre qu'il a un
petit avantage là on est sûr que 80
arrivés en cours ont échoué d'un point
chez m il a pas le choix elle voit
surgir voilà il survit encore il sort de
sa boîte c'est la seule branche surcroît
chronique va jouer et d'apprendre des
cinq as élite également et la chronique
va jouer d'un grand tour c'est sûr c'est
obligatoire
il ne note pas son coup il attend un
autre jeune homme est d'abord survola
voilà il est à noter les deux groupes
ont alors le cavalier est attaqué et
s'il bouge de cavaliers c6 à leur très
fort à la crise pensent s'est replongé
dans le callejon chellois tu me
démentira pas assez 6 oui tout à fait
c'est le cas les rouges et c6 tout de
suite
ces six là de toute façon on ne sait si
ce nas avec fougue et 6 à venir non là
c'est difficile va probablement ces
perdants pour garry kasparov
soyons objectifs c'est mal une position
très très difficile
il ya un pion passé l'ordinateur propre
en 3g 6 mai sur branger 6 tout
simplement engrangé 1 est le sien de 4
et perdu gros chaillot stéphane c'est le
seul groupe même si un seul coup alain
blondiaux talent de celle qui lie à
davos est forcée mais sur nous est moins
fort que tout à l'heure où c'est moins
fort que tout à l'heure mais c'est quand
même très fort puisque ici on a pas mal
de possibilités notamment le pouce et 6
avancé le pion comme des fous non désolé
nord le cren dames c'est cette élection
maintenant il ya le fond mais sa reprise
tout autre chose garry kasparov
il ya tout un tas de choses il est au
même club ce soir on peut voir la
position actuelle des joueurs
voilà c'est ça avantage pour kramix et
son arrogance et 5 des rouges
voilà la faiblesse du roi de chronos on
verra je ne suis quand même pas précis
non c'était pas précis mais ce n'est pas
grave voilà la position des premiers
kasparov réfléchi bilan pendu il prenait
tout à l'heure où son saoul et je
comprends pas ils prenaient tous les
pions qu'il reste 15 minutes à kasparov
et 14 akram xo ont joué combien coup il
leur reste à jouer stéphane le reste dix
coups à jouer
grosso modo est donc net avantage pour
chronique à cause de ces deux facteurs
le roi faible et le temps passé et là
nous avons des belles images mais
kasparov en pleine réflexion
il est très très mal garry kasparov mais
n'oublions pas que c'est
fini et qu'il peut se sortir de
n'importe quelle situation contre
n'importe qui granic fait même précision
qu'un crachin c'est quand même ça sent
le coup le coup de fatigue d'une fatigue
ouais mais bon on peut pas vouloir
akrami qui est comme pris 6 à trouver
des coups qu'on attendait pas du tout
c'est ça d'abord dans une position où
ils avaient l'air d'être très mal en
tous cas en passe d'être très mal il
trouve un conte fantastique qu'avait
laissé 17 et ensuite au moment de faire
nul de répéter les coupes il dit non il
dit non à kaspar en finit hop je te la
joues papilles à temps c'est pas fini
parce que maintenant c'est moi qui suis
mieux et que spotify l'amour j'espère
off qui fait la moue quand même dit
qu'il jette un oeil dans cette position
1,1 à une méchante mais admet le
problème c'est que l'on voit mal après
roy g6 roger 1 dames 7
comment les blancs progresse et
bédouines joue simplement ses 6 stephen
effet mesdames c'est cette famille est
fou mais sinon ça marche pas est ce
facile sur dame tranquille yade un
brancard et oui un sait si c'est rare de
gagner tout de suite on y définit le
pion de passer de granby qu'il adresse
depuis le début donc va jouer de réussir
cette fois joué comme c'est cette même
c'est simple dans cette position non
mais pas tout de suite 3g 6 échec 1 1 à
lorient ça va pas taxer cette même c7
est bien d'accord c'est possible et la
dame prend le 4/11 prend 24 et sur des
provinces en qu'il ya dans nos 7
et qu'on problème pour guérir espérances
il ya beaucoup de possibilités de toute
façon pour ramener très très dur on dire
il ya toujours ce couac 4 qui va asséner
un coup de massue au roi de kasparov
kramnik et relax un trawniki assez relax
take it et tranquille voilà il sera donc
lui a tout vu il a tout vu il fait dire
il est en train de montrer à kasparov
que là il a tout vu a essayé krainik
c'est un joueur kasparov maintenant une
fait des mimiques kaskarot viennent il
lui explique gary voilà c'est très
simple je fais comme toi maintenant
quand je suis gagnant je le montre
publiques ajouté fait signer qu'il avait
tout vu il semblerait que kramnik va
mener 2 0
et ça c'est la grosse surprise encore
une fois d'aujourd'hui on est passés par
des stades émotionnel très fort et loi
puisse compenser kasparov était gagnant
ainsi que kramnik arracher le nul est
maintenant ses chroniques et gagnant
alors qu'en fait probablement cramique
n'a jamais douté aucun moment qu'ils
pouvaient gagner venu et avoir davantage
non mais ce qui est dingue c'est que si
ça se trouve on a rien compris du tout
électronique était mieux toute la partie
stéphane c'est possible mais peu
probable dies la tienne à ce cas là au
coup cavalli ses 17 ans qui n'en avait a
priori pas pu être prévu quand la vie
est quand même parler d'une grands
cerveaux de la planète
c'est ça ait l'air assez aléatoire tout
ça c'est quand même incroyable ce que
moi j'ai si proche et si ces gens là
bien chronique de brême est là le
problème c'est qu est-ce qui débuta
sport 27 ou dames c'est cette passion
c'est pas pareil sont à 9,7 et c6 qui a
l'air de gagner tout de suite paille
puisque ça me rassure b6 une dame
d'acier cette héroïne des vies obligé
kasparov obligé dames c'est cette le
hoodie ni et l'art de la défense d'en
prendre quatre
c'est incroyable ce que fait kramnik
mais c'est vraiment complètement
incroyable d'emprunt 4 avec les boutons
+ et loire et on arrive à jouer b4 oui
mais qui a blessé six de kasparov qu'est
ce qu'on va essayer de faire une
forteresse avec toi mais tu as part of
de toute façon ce qui est sûr c'est là
on le voit avec l'ordinateur
chaque fois 2k sports joue un coup
l'évaluation reste la même en revanche
concret munich joue des fois son
avantage baisse quand les coups sont
forcés kasparov est une véritable
machine à trouver quand il ne faut pas
perdre kasparov est à 200% l'espérance
va trouver des ressources comme ça ça
serait incroyable si crâne il n'avait
pas gagné cette position non mais le fou
est très fort et loi le fouillent très
fort parce qu'il va passer une foule des
quatre noms nagy l'onef 6 il va jouer
dans le froid en cas d'échec il va jouer
avec à 20 près voilà monde analyse non
f4 sa part les 24 c'est très fort ça
détruit complètement les remparts autour
du roi noir c'est ça qu'il faut faire en
étant sûr d'un projet cette f4 je pense
que ça s'est affaiblie laurent blanc
aussi
non le roi blanc il ya le fou devant il
ya passé deux pièces pour tester rock
enfin ne serait-ce qu'un échec bon de
toute façon peut montrer la position
longue quelques instants ça va durer
quelques coups entre amis qui s'il va
jouer d'un prof quatre échelles 12
minutes kramnik contre 11 à kasparov
kasparov est obligé d'aller avec le roi
angers7
c'est fort c'est hélas plusieurs
possibilités sont attractives il ya le
coût des quatre qui est pas mal qui se
voit ainsi toute la structure c'est pas
mal mais d'un autre côté ça va il se
transfère la faiblesse à 5 ans b4 bien
le coup food et 4 si oui voilà c'est ça
la fout des 4 as l'air plus fort puis
sur ce cas les 6 lits sont jouées
d'entamer un fossé trois des quatre sûr
qu'elle sait s'ils sont faits tous ces
trois noms il y avait quatre dans le
cloud est en prison des cadres ah c'est
vrai mais c'est une finale de damas près
c'est bon on est d'accord avec un procès
s'est terminé
c'est sur wii n'est pas d'effet de la
rivière giguère non au final deux dames
sont pratiquement toujours gagnante avec
l'unc en plus c'est une idée fausse que
les finales d'homme peut faire nul c'est
juste sur des défenses imprécises
dans certains cas où des caf avec un
gros avantage évidemment pour chroniques
de toute façon voilà la position qu'ils
ont actuellement et cramique va sans
aucun doute prendre l'option sur le jour
apprendre le piano sur échelle c'est un
cadeau qui ne se refuse pas rob
évidemment évidemment 12 minutes
restantes à chacun des deux joueurs pour
jouer les huit derniers coups avant ce
fameux 60e coup en cas sport n'en
reviennent pas eu bien du mal à respirer
kasparov
il est quand même carreau c'est
incroyable ce que j'écris
il ne doit pas se tromper d'alger 8 à
chaque halte échec
d'où est ce que ça vient quel est cet
ovni comme se retrouve c'est juste pour
faire infléchir place par an
oui quel est ce coup étrange qu'est ce
qui a vu vladimir kramnik il se lève
relève sans que ses forces et du salaire
de diminuer les avantages blanc non mais
après notre dame des cinq échecs qu'est
ce qui se passe je ne comprends pas
c'est parce chimiques
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas jouer d'amd
5 dans cette position moyen d'un mécène
3g si ces forces est tout simplement il
va répéter les coups kramnik voilà il a
vu relève 5 il va revenir inversement se
laisse pas bluffer 1 ils essaient de
faire réfléchir kasparov mais ça marche
non il ne sait pas le faire infléchir il
veut juste prendre son temps il va
revenir des simples ouais mais adam 5
non y'a les cavaliers en prison non
roger si ces forces et voilà c'est une
petite répétition histoire de gagner du
temps c'est le geste technique stéphane
hains c'est le chien là et kasraoui pas
soit ils approchent du soixantième coup
voilà tout à fait et maintenant il va
prendre le pion de caméras il faut le
prendre mais ça en prend maintenant
parce qu'il fait d'avoir sévi vers le
mariole un coup de plus s'il fait
d'alger vite 3,5 d'amd 5 roger si c'est
la troisième position
pareil donc la casse porte peut demander
là nul et ne se privera pas de le faire
avant de le faire il faut qu'ils
demandent l'annulation de jouer le coup
avant de jouer coup voilà dit voilà
j'avais joué sa saveur à trois fois la
même position il ne faut pas tout à fait
sur la pendule il faut qu'ils à stoke
voilà faudrait même pas il peut demander
à l'arbitré mais elle demande la nulle
il joue son tir 1 cherche à envoyer des
petites kasparov lui a fait voilà d'un
point 4 voilà ils valent prend bien
jouer voilà voilà
c'est bien vu gaspard va jouer orange et
cette île je ne savais pas bon voilà
hélas hélas temps c'est là nous sommes
dans la position où kramnik a le choix
il peut jouer b4 il peut jouer les fous
des cafetiers pas mal non plus il va je
me fais des quatre années qui sait dans
son style il sait exactement que faire
de ces fous blêmir cramique oui presque
en plus simple des quatre il va venir en
c3 b4 voilà il se fout va être fabuleux
défenseur attaquant
voilà tout à fait le doublé attaque et
défense à la fois le fameux sabre de
samouraï qui attaque et qui défend même
temps est-ce que kasparov peut pas jouer
damas
six jeunes cassent porte ne peut rien
faire il est dans la boîte sont dame
cécilia dame cet échec et c'est un coup
de massue dans un ciel serein cavaliers
s'est terminée garry kasparov le hoodie
ni ne s'échappera pas cette fois ci
stéphane je crois que l'on assiste wes a
pas l'air facile à gagner 15 et 7 en
fout des quatre essais terminés wayne
iskra maintenant non mais réunir
chronique on a gagné d'autres des comme
ça stéphane c'est pas la première fois
qu'il se retrouve qu'une caution
gagnante thermique c'est vrai oui mais
kaspar c'est pas la première fois qu'ils
défendent et position désespérée
c'est le fameux sabre contre le bouclier
nos meilleurs sabre contre le meilleur
bouclier mais le bouclier si les
fichiers auraient et donc alors est ce
que cache la forêt dans l'élevage de
fond des cales chronique c'est trop dans
son style il adore ce genre de coups ce
genre de coup de fou ça le rend
justement complètement fou ça le rend
dingue ça le rendrait qu'elle fout des
quatre pouces et 3 et des quatre il va
commencer comme ça il y aura aucun bloc
dans cette partie il le tient
looking dans les cordes il ne lâchera
pas un cinq courageux pour chronique il
lui reste neuf minutes ça va à peu près
non c'est vrai faux pas faut pas
réfléchir trop long plus c'est pas se
tromper mais ne faut pas réfléchir de la
battre jusqu'au bout
gaspard va se battre jusqu'au bout
il a un pion de moins le fou en plus de
chronique est très fort le roi des
kasparov et aux fraises ça fait beaucoup
d'atouts pour les blancs c'est suffisant
pour dire que la position est gagnante
est fou d 4d qu'à travers très fort les
deux coups potentiel pour les blancs
sont probables en fout des 4 et/ou b4
plus tôt
d'ailleurs un
dans son ensemble a dit bien il est
serein et des tresseurs incroyable dans
le côté bon comment on passe quoi
problème ça va être une superbe victoire
de veka ce que kasparov ne menace pas
d'un me prends à sec sur food et quatre
non puisqu'il l'a menacé d'un set et
d'un break 6 à ce moment là avec un matt
à la clé
barak mais en tout cas ça récupère tous
les pions c'est sûr
holmes
question surtout des caps qui laissait 6
ou 7 3 qui aurait paquet pour la scène
je ne crois pas damas huit ils se
fourvoient vladimir ou pas non je pense
que ça a l'air pas mal son cousin a vite
ça a l'air d'être bien vu elle tombe
bien vu ouais dame prend 1,6 en mai
quand même de me prends à saint prime et
avait quatre mais quatre seulement ont
passé les quatre dames un échec
un proche d'eux dans laquelle chargé
trois du d'échec plus d'échecs et le puy
ainsi c'est en prison que rossi cette
emprise possible elle a tout vu par
notre annick talent à huit attaques le
pion à 6 ont préféré sous des cats et
poussé 3,1 textures manquent pas sûr
c'est pas forcément les couturières le
tout tranquille qui sont le plus
efficaces cramique a démontré que les
coudes entre guillemets de déséquilibres
sont aussi très fort ah là là on a peur
qu'ils se trompent pas d'un permis qu on
a peur que crysis autres en disant que
ça fait on a peur on aimerait en a peur
surtout qu'après la partie de samedi
kramnik meilleurs délais leur aide et
remo je ne rate rate deux fois le gain
et ça serait dommage pour la suite du
match tout simplement parce que s'ils
travaillent gagnent ça va obliger
kasparov
enfin elle est le chercher à aller le
chercher parce que pour l'instant
pour l'instant il n'y est pas allé trop
vite
les souvenirs ce qui est beau avec ses
joueurs c'est que le moindre avantage
peut se transformer en un point
c'est probablement un des plus beaux
matchs qu'on ait vu depuis assez
longtemps pour l'instant façon qu'est-ce
qu'on refera difficulté c'est pas tous
les jours alors la chronique sept
minutes contre neuf minutes à cazaux
l'ordinateur annonce que le seul coup et
d'un point à 5 dans le troisième il faut
voir la position rapidement un caspar
veulent trouver un corner bien de mettre
la dame en débit nous à la majorité nous
assurer tout à l'heure que quatre ans
votre katana un force et il menace le
cavalier et kasparov va jouer c'est une
certitude 2.5 qui est le seul coup que
l'ordinateur propose et réfléchie
kasparov irréfléchie et 9 minutes à sa
pendule contre 7 minutes à kramnik pour
jouer quatre coups ensuite ils ont une
demi heure supplémentaire et 10 secondes
parcours est tout à fait ce qui peut
donc nous faire jouer jusqu'à mercredi
matin
oui et d'ailleurs c'est compliqué ce
n'est pas dans le 17 la faute de
kasparov la faute de kasparov dalle 17
c'est une faute
c'est terminé ici c'est terminé
apparemment après le coup g2 g3 il n'y a
plus rien kasparov va perdre le pion à 6
en ligne ici ça serait terminée après
j'ai trois arénas et dams et 6 annonce
n'a pas d'homme si non pourquoi j'ai
trois parce que sinon il ya menace
perpétuelle c'est ça que se passe-t-il
heijmans à saint-pierre rituel kasparov
je menace d'amd un échec
je ne comprends pas il s'est passé
quelque chose le thème de cette
chronique et joueurs ou h2 tempo non six
de ces curieux
c'est curieux c'est curieux
proche de jouer à tempo par vladimir
kramnik donc il ya eu un échange de
coups a tempo
c'est curieux hélas hélas c'est très
chaud on est dans la boîte
nous y sommes complètement dans
d'étroits kasparov apparemment n'a rien
vu je pense qu'on est dans les dix
dernières minutes de cette partie
stéphane en tout cas je l'espère eh bien
là c'est très très chaud
mon parce qu'on fait je
je
c'est bientôt terminé donc vladimir
kramnik sur dan détroit devrait jouer et
d'apprendre à 6 mais tant qu'outil dans
la boîte
nous l'espérons c'est le 58ème poudre
est trop à quoi joue à caen monique
kasparov comme d'habitude saisi sa
chance qu'elle soit enfin je vous donne
des 3 à noter quand même la main
attention il ya d'un match 7
damages cet échec menace très près ce
que je fais un chèque perpétuelle c'est
pour ça qu'il faut calculer précisément
coranique qui devra si on peut montrer
l'échiquier de démonstration ici très
important voilà c'est comme ça crame
nick devrait prendre ce pion et sur dan
h cet échec venir avec le roi sur les
fans seront sous le psg 3 s'exposant à
des réseaux de maths mais apparemment
rien ne marche
benoît y en a marre je l'espère on d'une
dame seule pour mater c'est quand même
peu gênant il ya une dame et des pions
on voit pas à wayne on met des pions il
ya un pion d'à priori ça ne devrait pas
marché ça marche pas normalement g nick
ne devrait pas se laisser bluffer mais
n'oublions pas qu'il n'a pas
d'ordinateur ici après oui mais
attention à l'ordinateur peut se tromper
aussi on a bien vu qu'ils se trompent
étant régulièrement ils voient pas
l'aider que ça dépasse 5 où il est
largué parce qu'il faut rappeler qu'elle
les combinaisons sont énormes
il semble néanmoins n'y a rien pour nous
engagerons possible est incroyable mais
gary kasparov une fois de plus cédé sa
chance on peut mentionner ça
là
que va jouer le dit mir cramique
c'est très très chaud il lui reste cinq
minutes c'est vraiment extrêmement chaud
haye de juger 3 il a joué j'ai trois
plus sécure c'est pas mal bien g 3g 3 ça
a l'air d'être confirmée par la machine
des sports je devrais jouer b4 pour
défendre son bureau à 600 mhz et la c6
non on a eu des hauts et ses 6 ces 6
patients ça permet peut-être un échec
taper dessus mais c'est compliqué
grasset c'est extrêmement chose mais
c'est extrêmement kasparov trouve des
possibles à la cave satisloh tiananmen
le cavalier kasparov
ils veulent amener sur la case de 5,10
veut créer des contre chance il a créé
des contrôles chance déjà un hic
c'est horrible c'est horrible c'est oryx
est en train de se passer
il reste quatre minutes 40 à chronique
pour jouer le coup kasparov
on lui dit pas deux fois qu'il ya un roi
et mis un peu en danger alors la dame
vsat d'autres amis peut-être où ces
scissions choix tous est si dense et si
ça demain et secteur que tu es libyen et
je sais que perpétuer sur ces sites je
verrais mieux tandis que je donne
bessette dans cette position d'après 1,6
à l'art a toujours d'actualité problème
francis est d'actualité dans bessette
c'est probablement plus fort pour que
loïc à venir qu'est ce qui a bien joué
et d'amener ça je crois que c'était
beaucoup
la dernière fois j'ai six projets si
c'est plus d'échecs n'a pas tué l'ont
fait ces 6 après un oui dame bessette et
la casse pour peugeot et g4 des sports
que joe g4 avec ou souples
éventuellement des sports va sans doute
rouge et quatre meilleurs espoirs menace
de faire nul c'est ça la menace du gaz
par an pour l'instant mais c'est peut
être un modèle menacé non mais c'est ça
ça il s'en sortir comme ça il est dans
une menace entre guillemets de faire nul
faisant un des échecs perpétuelle autour
du roi blanc il faut kramnik empêche
d'investir le risque un coup à jouer à
ne pas jouer f5 kasparov f5 il y aurait
eu malheureusement fou projet cinq
habitants du clos âge et sur j'écarte le
problème c'est qu'il ya un loup s 4 avec
quoi le mans 18e 1h01 gains pourquoi
puisque on n'aurait plus qu'à prendre le
cavalier arrive en finale dames c'est la
tendance avec 400 projets 4 x 4 comment
tu prends le cavalier bas j'attends
qu'il bouge je contrôle tout et 15 en
fait ouais mais attention la kz2 n'est
plus protégé oui je la défends avec le
roi
ça c'est ça ressemblerait un geste
technique si c'était possible il faut
être être tu protèges plus non plus le
pion ces 5 g 4 x 100 m dames des gardes
et stéphane fête des sports fait quand
même un bon classement fait incroyable
ce qu'ils trouvent des contres chance
alors qu'il avait l'air y avait hier
foutu et il a toujours l'air foutu
d'ailleurs mai mais moins qu'avant ils
compliquent qui complique
nick c'est de trouver les meilleurs
coups si chrome ni gratte encore
aujourd'hui mais enregistre alors là
c'est six mois j'essaie je veux pas
rater ce prof
alors là voilà c'est la haye a cavalé
j'ai quatre échecs au la ccir cavaliers
ou 5
c'est sur ces sept cavaliers j'ai quatre
échecs avec avec un échec compliqué
quoique non pas trop notre un droit que
je crois que cet art à la la il ya
encore des trucs est encore bien des
diables il est trop fort kasparov
c'est le ovini d'emblée ccc c'est clair
c'est clair qu'on va s'en sortir
peut-être ces six à l'heure d'un gagner
je sais pas non c'est pas plus
regardable 4
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce qui est
sûr c'est que je ne sais pas je ne sais
plus
et kasparov se lève très psychologique
non mais quel beau nom mais ces chocs il
s'échappe tout le temps il se faufile
c'est une anguille on n'arrive pas même
quand on est gagnant il faut gagner
krainik celle de découvre pour la
deuxième fois consécutive
ça c'est quand même un handicap énorme
si on n'arrête pas gagner quand on est
gagnant
effectivement
ah oui parce que là
ic deux minutes pour jouer un coup
peut-être qu'il va jouer tamo 7
je ne sais pas mais l'un d'eux mêmes
salaires ça sert à rien kallio scène
quand même l'équipe de 5 quand même
c'est vrai que menacé de faire nul c'est
pas une option
là c'est plus difficile de gagner que de
le faire nul c'est vrai
tellement vrai oh lalalalalalalalala
natation kramnik doit trouver des je
pense qu'il va jouer c6 et c7 problème
c'est qu'il a rien fait avec son coude à
huit dames bessette
il a fait captiver les noirs encore une
fois il aurait dû se contenter des
muselets avec faut des cats est fou
c'est 3 c'était beaucoup plus forts
stéphane il a voulu terminer garry
kasparov
alors que ça ne se termine pas comme ça
un kasparov c'est l'horreur
l'ordinateur mention de 9.6 comme étant
le meilleur moyen de gagner
d'après insiste cavaillon 5 menace qu'un
léger cats a détruit complètement le
rempart du roi blancs et les noirs
menace vraiment de faire un échec
perpétuelle c'est à l'air au clip le
mans vraie saloperie
c'est incroyable crâne il va encore une
fois laissé s'échapper kasparov que de
retournement que de retournement
vraiment une très très belle partie
vraiment pour la plus grande joie de
tous nos internautes de notre
réalisateur et de toute l'équipe de
diagonale nous sommes extrêmement
satisfaits du jeu des deux joueurs dans
ce sont deux champions d'exception qui
nous font un super de spectacles et ici
nous en sommes donc à 59 pour jouer
reste une minute akram ligue pour jouer
160 et le coup après quoi ils sont à
créditer d'une demi heure supplémentaire
et de 10 secondes par coup problème
c'est que gicle d'impro ainsi a quand
même le coup recommandé par l'ordinateur
quand même d'un emprunt à 6 maintenant
qu'il ya plus le damage cet échec
maintenant la menace des noirs c'est de
jouer cavalier ou 5 avec des échecs
garry kasparov va jouer c'est très
probable
le vétéran demandé tu étudies il va
ouvrir mais tu dis qu'on n'a pas le
temps
la dame prend 1,6
la dîmière cramique 60e koutia kasparov
de jouer alors que malheureusement une
loi dont nous quitter parce que des
télévisions on demandait des images de
ce match qui doivent être envoyées sous
peu et ça nous prive de la fin de ce
match c'est un peu dommage
là
après dans prend 1,6 les noirs doivent
jouer cavalier ou cinq qui probablement
mais il ya peut-être malheureusement il
ya peut-être des possibilités pour
kasparov de faire d une nulle une chèque
perpétuelle voire même un math possible
après cavaliers ou 5
il ya peut-être un math possible il faut
faire très attention très très attention
pour kasparov chronique ajoute son 107e
couvre la cavalière 5 a été jouée par
kasparov et là c'est plus du tout la
même musique puisque les noirs ont
réussi à encercler laura blanc il ya des
menaces il ya des menaces de maths
contre laurent blanc et ça c'est
horrible
c'est horrible il ya des menaces de
maths contre le roi blanc
cramique ici est sous la menace de
kasparov heures et menace de maths
il va y avoir des menaces de match
puisque les noirs vont peut-être joué le
coup g3 et g5 g4 en fermant le roi blanc
et chroniques risquent d'être sous la
menace de maths c'est ça va peut-être le
pousser à accepter la nulle
et oui très difficile
le cavalier de kasparov deviennent très
menaçant
qu'est-ce qu'on va probablement arriver
à tirer là nul de cette partie et ça
c'est encore c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour chronique est probablement rater
encore une fois le gain si kasparov
arrive à s'en sortir
ils menacent d'en fermer le roi blanc
par le coup gsm g4 suivi de cavalière
trois échecs et ensuite la donne bien
sûr la première rangée menaçant d'alger
un math et forcé antranik asséné à
l'échec perpétuelle lui même contre
attaque de kasparov incroyable
incroyable granik a laissé kasparov
activer ses pièces au centre de
l'échiquier alors qu'elle était
complètement désorganisée
s'il avait posté son fou en d4 le
cougaing eux ça n'aurait pas jamais été
possible à cause de faux point cavaliers
tout simplement
et là c'est une autre paire de manches
il
hélas oui gros problème est une
chronique qui
et plus du tout dans la même situation
c'est chaud de lancre amis qu'il reste
une demi-heure pour terminer la partie
et 34 minutes à kasparov plus 10
secondes par coup c'est incroyable
incroyable ce qui est en train de se
passer
kramnik une nouvelle fois domine
kasparov dans la partie avec les blancs
mais n'arrive pas à terminer la partie
kasparov s'échappe
voilà qu'à la tête dans les mains
je rappelle que nous sommes ici à
londres pour suivre ce match entre
vladimir kramnik et garry kasparov
kramnik mène d'un point et là dans la
sixième partie chronique de nouveau a
pris davantage contre kasparov
comme samedi dernier avec les blancs
mais il semblerait que kasparov et
trouver les moyens de contre-attaquer et
une menace maintenant vraiment le roi de
chroniques ce qui peut conduire à la
partie nulle voire même en cas de gaffes
de kramnik ça peut même conduire à la
défaite
samnick a probablement dû jouer des
coups et précis dans cette partie
sur la fin malheureusement
kasparov menace clairement en échec du
cavalier sur la case g3 sur la kf3
pardon
et oui alors que là comme l'a dit mir
cramique adama 8 le coût proposé par à
l'ordinateur avec le seul coup d'oeil en
proposer parlant d'un seul coup proposé
par l'ordinateur qui semble gagner
encore la partie mais on voit pas trop
comment tu parce que là kasparov
que faire des échecs peut jouer g4 par
exemple sur g4 stéphane je t'arrête tout
de suite il y adam g 8 échecs et et des
gros problèmes qui arrivent vont pas
trop quoi il n'ya par exemple sur re5
des échanges la dame mais l'om est
obligé de jouer ça ne casse pas on va
réfléchir ici c'est sûr et donc c'est
cuit en fait faut une faut trouver des
solutions et on sait que ce n'est pas
facile
insupportable je conseille
akram nique de téléphoner avec quelqu'un
qui aurait un ordinateur tout ce qu'il
faut derrière
enfin là stéphane quand même c'est un
moment dramatique du marche vraiment
dramatique c'est très très important
alors que le nombre d'internautes
connectés est énorme pour ne pas dire
illimité à la chronique là les très
beaux plans très bons plans en a
actuellement deux kramnik est en train
de jauger kasparov lettre indique unis
alors garé
vas-y j'ai tout vu l'anguille encore
voient ce plan voilà est-ce que tu t'en
sors gary est bien john quel talent quel
plan fantastique de kramnik en train de
jauger kasparov du haut de son fauteuil
en cuir de son côté léger alors que
kasparov billets rappelons le à une
chaise chaise médiévale
qu'est-ce qu'on ne trouve pas c'est
superbe c'est la crainte drame qui a
disparu quand il est parti c'est marrant
il est parti cramique il a regardé
christophe diot de ses deux mètres et la
et quelle est la menace de chroniques la
a6 a7 a8 way quelque chose dans ce goût
là faut que kasparov trouve quelque
chose pour coincer le roi de kramnik est
menacée et mat ou aux tchèques perpétuel
un des deux forces entre amis qu'à faire
lui-même un échec perpétuelle selon
anwar
des trous et on sait que dans mes
cavaliers c'est très très fort pour
attaquer en tout à fait redoutable en
variante possible que nous allons
envisager grâce à notre échiquier de
démonstration qu'elle j'ai quatre échecs
qu'a rédigé quatre échecs quand même ça
se regarde
apparemment il faudrait monter l'euro en
a je crois
là nous sommes fatigués donc ne nous
fions quand même beaucoup à l'ordinateur
d'autant plus qu'une position qui se
prêtent beaucoup sont malades a fait ici
sur dame est rens il y aurait le coup
d'angelo dame g2 ramenant la dame son
humour avant le coin de paradis et non
par warp un cavalier qui serait
sanctionné par et sur cavalli profs on
échange les dames quand même puisque les
pions - m regardons 27 27 f1 droit
grands cavaliers très très sévèrement
punis par f5 échec le roi devient f3 et
là d'un match est un échec avec une
enfilade
et oui il superbe le roi leur doit
bouger la super pro kramnik ce serait
une horreur évidemment on sent que la
table la date sera prise allez jouer
kasparov il est d'un or et l'élevage de
question donc ici bonjour et d'histoire
échec d'alger 2 c'est à dire que kramnik
n'a pas le choix là commence à voir des
coûts forcé cette intervention puisque
kasparov peut pas jouer tu vois mais il
faut il faut kasparov continuant journal
d un continuer la lutte
mais il a le rôle à lecavalier emprise
la non puisqu'il avait cinq matches
stéphane
non mais là on peut simplement
conception en france je pense que ça
sera le roi a l'air d'un doux sales
draps
c'est sans appel de conception élargie
sept mois g7 non parce que je prends
quelques billets pour la non ici je
crois que c'est terminé
a priori kasparov l'anguille ne s'en est
pas sorti dans cette désagréable si
chronique à trouver cette défense damas
huit la position actuelle il a trouvé
tous en hélium vladimir kramnik pour
kasparov il ya cru et nous y avons cru
aussi tu m'énerves ce boudin à 8 donc un
nouveau retournement de situation non
part au tournoi situation kramnik été
mieux la question c'est est-ce que la
contre attaque de kasparov tous les
passés et bien apparemment il semblerait
que trawick et tout vu qu'est ce qui se
passe sur g4g 4 c'est un coup
intéressant les cartes c'est un coup
très intéressant on va le tenter on
reste mené 4 à l'air de mettre le roi
blanc dans la boîte
j'écarte apparemment ici stéphane brière
une pointe d'un g8 échec
oui si le roi vient engage 5 salaire
intéressant après à william at mais il y
a damas 7 matches non la machette c'est
contre les stéphanois
iliad a mérité chèque d'un invité cheikh
kane g6 pour sa force comme les jets
s'ils savent aussi bon et du coup on
joue plus et qui ont tous le fion
critères la bourgeoisie et ses tables ça
c'est bien voilà donc ça s'est fini
puisque ce roi f5
évidemment c'est du même ordre damages
cet échec le ramènerait à s'interposer
et on pousse ses pions
c'est le plan ici ouais et c'est fini
voici donc la presse que les noirs
doivent aller protéger donc à jacques
gardians et vert instantanément ses fans
je crois qu'on peut le dire donc la
casse par d'autres votre choix droit g7
l'anguille doit trouver autre chose roy
g7 s'est pas vraiment un coup c'est un
deuxième coup
puisque ça permet beaucoup de choses
pour walf 7.7 c'est pareil ça permet aux
blancs jouer dame b cet échec de gagner
du temps devront venir se replacer je
pense pas que ça soit moi monsieur je ne
suis peut-être pas là l'idée pas
forcément on peut jouer roger dossier
mais voici que je me range est en train
de me roger de weck les bourses est un
très fort très fort coup mieux vaut
prévenir que guérir
alors qu'amélie g4 cominar transposerait
donc non parce qu'on me l'a scrabble et
prend 1,3 suivis de damon aux échecs
mais ça ne marchera pas ça marchera pas
de rodez 3e rang des défenses ici je
crois qu'on peut le dire au 61e coup
stéphane et à exactement 21h07
et oui c'est très très chaud il
semblerait que kasparov soit de nolwenn
fois dans la boîte et que kramnik
tiennent enfin sa deuxième victoire et
si on voit la difficulté que les joueurs
ont à gagner des parties sur tf1 kramnik
même quand il est parti gagnant de
samedi dernier il n'arrive pas à gagner
ça veut dire que même kasparov pour
gagner il va souffrir oui exactement
granic doit doit avoir le même calcul
d'échappatoire que kasparov
il doit aussi très fort dans ce genre de
coups mais kasparov s'est quand même sa
spécialité et au je pense que si
question fait gagnant dans une partie de
gagnoa sans problème parce que c'est sa
réputation quand il est gagnant il gagne
personne n'a que kasparov
on n'arrête pas la mafia russe à noter
que le coin f5 sur leur éviter aussi par
dame g8 suivi de dames pranger cinq
essais terminés dès s'est très vite
terminé ici garric imowicz kasparov
troisième champion du monde est en train
de passer le pouvoir à son dauphin ce
qu'on est en train de vivre c'est un
très grand moment et c'est en direct est
probablement un des moments historiques
de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs un
champion du monde va passer la main à un
nouveau et ça c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on voit ça un mapping sas n'a vu que
13 champions du monde dans l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs matches en 16 parties
stéphane c'est donc légitime
ce n'est pas un titre qui à pile ou face
et oui incroyable va dit n'être un
niveau inscrire son nom dans les
tablettes de l'histoire en battant garry
kasparov ont craqué ainsi le débat ici
il aura pris une très très grosse option
sur la victoire finale 2 0 en avance 2-0
et kasparov qui n'a plus beaucoup de
fois les blancs kasparov dans les cordes
puisque ils ont le même nombre de fois
les deux langues
d'ailleurs stéphane oui mais on a déjà
joué six parties on sera plus que 5
folie moulins expérience pour marquer
deux points c'est énorme
tout à fait sachant que chronique ne
peut pas perdre avec les bourses s'il
veut faire nous oui s'il veut faire nul
fera nul est donc fort être clair qu'à
sport retrouve quelque chose avec les
blancs et la chronique peut le laisser
venir
hélas ses casseroles qui va prendre des
risques oui tout à fait et un grand
moment
d'autant plus que craint ni pour
continuer je voulais des pitchouns et
gary shaw faut que kravitz fasse
attention après parce que c'est pas
facile à gérer une avance de deux points
et loi pas facile à gérer mais c'est
quand même plus facile qui retarde de
pons aimerait c'est vrai quoi que non
dans un retard et point il faut jouer
pour le ghana moi j'entends d'ailleurs à
sept points c'est pas trop ça aussi je
veux pour le grain c'est une option on
peut faire ce qu'on veut quand on est
deux points devant sont pas s'amuser une
partie on peut
allez faire un tour chez les grecs boffo
bref interagit l'instant est en retard
c'est un grand moment là je crois que
l'anguille ne va pas s'échapper mais ça
il est en retard au temps puisqu'il a
moins de 25 minutes magic gary est cuit
cry kasparov cherche une solution
elle a heureusement que ma chronique à
trouver ce coût d'un habitant cramique a
tout vu à chaque fois ils trouvent des
coûts et heureusement parce qu'alors
fouilles où nous attend sur lescure gace
pompage rick chiarelli c4 ouais non
parce qu'elle ya toujours dame g8 échec
même j'habitais chez avec peut-être elle
n'en mettez ces quatre tensions
s'étaient fameux les blancs demande qu'à
jouer un coup comme dan f3c termine ils
poussent leurs pions un vrai comme des
cheminots non parce quelqu'un il ya eu
cinq sont des monstres en n'oubliant pas
que qu'asseoir peut répéter les coups il
peut le faire qu'à laisser 4 honnêtement
je ne crois pas vraiment l'idée c'est de
prendre mais qu'est ce que je comprends
pas qu'ils essaient capté six passes sur
a6 et bien cavaliers prend à trois tués
au front on va regarder dans me2 échec
est surnommé g2 filière d'un match à
laquelle chacun peut tuer mais ce n'est
pas sûr d'ailleurs apparemment à six a
l'air d'être confirmée par l'ordinateur
donc nous allons voir ça quel point de 3
ici il y a un petit coup pervers comme
on les aime damas huit échecs
ah oui il récupère le cavalier avec la
dame ce qui empêche les échecs
perpétuelle voilà tout à fait et là
c'est fini c'est l'islam aulas
kasparov recherche chez aba de cavaliers
ces cas pour gary alors que le temps
avance on va envoyer
eh bien je pense qu'il faut d'urgence
téléphoner
au revoir l'ensemble
bon alors voilà donc pourquoi pourquoi
non mais c'est ton destin kasparov
stéphane c'est ton destin
kasparov y veiller le petit gars y
il est quasi parole ne trouve rien il
est cuit y va encaisser sa deuxième
défaite du match et ça c'est
complètement inattendu complètement
inouïe complètement incroyable
ça fera 4 2 en faveur de platini rck
ramener mais trouve rien kasparov qui
cherche mais ne trouvent rien à 8 le
constituent moi j'ai c'est qu'il veut
faire ce procès sur franchi cette qui
enlève les variantes avec dame g8
eva il va re menacé g4 ce sur quoi j'ai
cette chronique jouera sans doute roger
de suivi de 9,3 mais non ils gagnent 1
ou 5
oui et après roger de que jouent les
noirs des g4 d'accord ça ne laisse rien
si sa menace de mettre le roi en boîte
oui mais cabaye f3 et d'amd un décor
c'est un peu long oui c'est un peu long
mais un peu long
et ce n'est pas bon c'est vrai que les
blancs font vite dame maintenant à six à
s'être les blancs sont des véritables
fusé dans cette question les coeurs
blancs sont des flèches et ici je crois
que kasparov peut rendre les armes d'un
instant l'un dans la mer il et ce n'est
pas dans le style du personnage ne
capitulera pas comme ça et la conférence
de presse va être explosive avec des
journalistes venus du monde entier qui
pose des questions d'enfer je peux vous
invite donc à revoir les conférences de
presse et notamment celle là qui sera
évidemment en direct ce risque de pas
répondu tout maître dépité aaaaaah piège
des 4 vallées du 4 échecs
donc là le coup c'est relâche de rage 3
au match 3 forcément il y a également
roger 1 mais moins bien donc il faut
joueur aura le choix avec un va jouer un
rallongement à munich calcule et tout ça
il va juste vérifier ses variantes
tranquillement il faut pas se tromper il
faut pas se tromper parce qu'on met
aussi se trompent place et si l'on
classe et une cata smith qui passent sur
3 3 6 6 1
kasparov joue f5
eh bien on l'avait déjà mentionné je
crois stéphane gilli adam g 8 échecs et
d'un projet 5
alors ici aussi on ne sonnait pas sûr
puisqu'il sort est mat tout de suite non
annoncée d'un projet s'avère les cache
avec avec le fait qu'il te fais mon papa
m'a tout de suite ou cicinho rue mathe
d'amour f1 et d'un match en date
oui mais ça arrive plus vite composent
cette même dame et femmes at 9 h
catherine damas pour être précis mais
bon ça n'arrivera pas j'échoue et
vladimir kramnik prendre le pion des
syndicats avec échec
il est cuit gary pas de façon chronique
christian et avec rami très serein mais
par contre il ne gère pas notre stress
en énergie repas notre stress il nous
angoisse il est 21h15
il s'est très très chaud ici c'est très
chaud kramnik va gagner c'est sûr à
condition qu'ils ne se trompent pas
comme samedi dernier
mais là je crois qu'il ne fera pas
d'erreur laverty kasparov samedi dernier
13 [ __ ] c'est horrible allez vous l'a
dit viens tu le tiens tu le tiens il est
apte à merci c'est l' angoisse tuer la
bête c'est jamais facile il faut en
finir il faut finir avec la vette les
ailes ce débat elle se dévoile jusqu'au
mans et oui mais comme diffusera pas
rouages 3g pas si vous avez déjà tué un
cochon mais c'est une horreur
là c'est pire que ça c'est un kasparov
kasparov des bois de kasparov des voix
une partie tout à fait passionnante
stéphane éclatante explosive 13 km
serait une domination de vladimir crown
et qui va se solder nous l'espérons par
une victoire qui provoquera kasparov a
peut être poussé dans ses derniers
retranchements
ah oui que ce fardeau au mur ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut voir pour le
croire
dès jeudi prochain avec les pièces
blanches il va falloir enfin ils sortent
quelque chose qui n'est pas qu'ils
trouvent un truc et parce que la mairie
kasparov et dans la boîte comme nick va
monter le roi il va prendre son roi et
l'avancé ils croient pas en ligue 2 live
quel est ce qu'il aurait vu quelque
chose chronique mais non on sait
maintenant qu'il fait des mimiques
gasparo viennent et que donc ça ça ne
veut rien dire du tout en tout 4 1
n'échappe à l'oeil de la caméra là il
est rouge et nez rouge alors méchant
restaurants vivent vérité c'est rohff là
il sent que la défaite approche
disciplinée raid c'est qu'il est raide
il sait qu'il est raide mais mais il
attend la faute et chronique peut faire
des fautes on a vu qu'il était illettré
car il est ce qu'on appelle trois quarts
- lieu fait des fautes il est peu craqué
non mais va jouer mais je crois il n'a
pas le choix tout à son chrono mais
l'énergie aie qu'elle est un échec qui
vient à angers 2 qu'est ce qui se
passait j'ai qu à l epr en intégrant à
l'échec perpétuelle saison jadot c'est
nul
immédiat c'est un nul qui suit
immédiatement sur trois il a tout de
suite il n'y a pas de soleil se
transformer en maths
certaines variantes de certaines
variantes et des way avec un matt des
épaulettes à la clé
photographe un petit bain des épaulettes
un ouvrage 3 et force est là qu est ce
qui fait qu il peut prendre 1 3 mais non
il ya dix huit ans a dit oh lalala
lalala orages 3f scène qui veut jouer
une scène kasparov c'est sûr va sur les
ressentis faire le tour g5 avec échec
c'est oui mais après
après l'écran
je la donne mais son roi s'en va mais
ils bougent ou la dame non non non mais
c'est pas possible pas je ne sais pas et
il ya toujours d'un bref une noire jcat
qui va emmener en gsm mais non ça ne
tient pas un gardien matt bien madonna
ya pas de max fabien makhzen ont ainsi
signé un match après cinq points les
cinq grossistes mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait bon je roi jeu 3-2 roi g4
directement on peut vous montrer cette
variante chronique va jouer ce coup
droit je crois c'est une certitude sur
toi stéphane la banque propose le coup
qui perd en ligne f 5 passes et les
seuls coûts d'un g8 échec alors on a g6
trois fils on existe d'un projet 5 et
celle d'apprendre les cinq échecs 3 o6
hélas féroce français et les féroé
france et y est c'est parti
attention je vais jouer caspar a joué 25
c sur c'est le seul coup non non il me
joue à plein
mais c'est le seul coup pour tenter de
continuer la partie là c'est 3 septembre
sa part terminé au printemps il peut
abandonner
rappelons extrait absolue c'est tout à
fait exceptionnel
d'autant plus que ça sera suivie d'une
conférence de presse où les joueurs se
livreront aux questions des journalistes
ces normes seraient très intéressés
l'angoissé vraiment c'est intenable
intenable d'autant plus qu'il ya un
stress multiples on est tout à fait dit
ça c'est insoutenable
je crois que là
granic à l'air serein quand même mais
nous on est hyper tendu on est très très
chaud ici on est à fond il faut qu'ils
jouent f54 signer seul coup non il ne
jouera peut être ses anciens qu'est-ce
qui va jouer d'autres non il peut jouer
tf1 m g2 d'ambea non pour conserver un
potentiel d'attac ça déplace adam drame
un drame un attaquant le pion au passé
non ça s'annonce et l'autre demain il
raconte j'ai quatre ses fans damien
c'est bien parce que ça te des fonds
indirectement kg 4 ah oui on peut
montrer cette variante qu'il varie en
menaçant sa fantasque le têt dame f5
voilà gary cooper va jouer la f1
vladimir kramnik et hop chedjou est
d'alger de on a déjà d'une sous peine
d'être maths et maintenant dmb un très
probable lecavalier n'est pas prenable à
cause du mat sur quoi l'ordinateur
propose dam des cinq qui ressemble un
bon coup qui a la couleur du bon coup et
ça sent puisque maintenant sur dalle f1
ça change tout il y a trois projets 4
puisque f5 n'est plus jouable
la dame contrôle ancêtres kf5 ici
doctement c'est une c'est un fort coup
et là ça ressemble à la fin ça passe
lors de jouer il y aurait cinq minutes
ils cherchent à paul il ne trouve plus
ne trouvera pas mal d'autres avaient
cherché il veut pas mourir caspar ans
nikki troupe affontera questions
figuraient cinq minutes quand un exemple
de minutes il n'a pas encore eu et nous
combien de temps nous reste-t-il
stéphane vient il nous reste à peine 25
minutes 25 minutes
et oui sachant que la conférence de
presse deux suivants est ce assez
nikon a déjà abandonné
je prends vraiment belles images
on envoie dix minutes d'une cassette
avant mais c'est chiant très fin oui
c'est mieux de montrer la fin les si la
bête n'est pas morte
s'il n'y a rien à montrer les terriens
exactement bonjour vraiment voir la
galerie garrigues simovic kasparov
je rappelle que nous sommes ici à
l'ombre pour suivre donc une mise à mort
une corrida c'est l'estocade en ce
moment même une garry kasparov ne se
débat pratiquement plus il est
complètement amorphe il ne peut plus
bouger il n'empêche dans les mains il
cherche des solutions à quelques
centimètres de la table allocs krainik
je crois est parti il a quitté la table
manière chronique
on va pouvoir confirmer sa à laval à la
caisse que c'est tendu c'est incroyable
5 juan comment kasparov arrive à
retrouver des contres chance est-ce que
ce cas les fous des quatre caisses
cramique aurait pas tuer le contre jaune
je pense que fout des quatre été
préférable ça aurait évité la chronique
de se prendre la tête dans cette
situation mais que dire qu'il ya sept
ans christophe les méfaits de travail
qui n'est monté sur ressorts annick en
plus à paea passait pas idée puisque le
jour où un chien quand même catégorie
qui était une fois au même bilan
travnik est donc encore là et très
concentré il a été le cas mais de
kasparov a trouvé les classes c'est trop
fort ce qu'en dit [ __ ] qu'est-ce qu'il
est fort à vélo ce pas claire parce
qu'en fait de quelques espoirs français
6 pouvaient bondir à 1,5 plus vite quand
el kram camia
peut-être que cramique aurait bien joué
c'est une possibilité qu'il ne faut pas
avec duj et stephen cravic aurait
peut-être peut-être bien joué cela resta
cela reste à démontrer la dîmière
chronique garry kasparov
le king en dix films d'horreur c'est
l'horreur comment cette manne est là
donc une fois de plus nous assistons à
une sorte de relâchement après le 60e
coup comme d'habitude c'est le touche
c'est le dos des raisons qu'il nous faut
retrouver stéphane il faut trouver un
troisième souffle c'est du très grand
spectacle la torti n'est pas remplacé la
la la la la remarque il marquait la fin
mark il ne sait plus là garry kasparov
et il a l'air content et chroniques sont
va des chroniques s'en va c'est superbe
c'est ça se passe à une 15 40
c'est excellent kasparov et cuits et il
s'en rend compte il provoque le dépeint
de fait venir à munich s'est tendu au
red star a envie de jouer moins bien
elle joue gabrielle chou dit je
t'attends gaye aux [ __ ] c'est super
c'est superbe
le front plissé alors ils se décident
pas de ce qu'il faut que tous les coups
perdre il veut un jouet 2010 mais ça
perd alors il revient il essaye de
trouver un autre mais de se taire aussi
saint père aussi c'est ça qui est beau
qu'il se fasse sur des f 5 et bien sûr
19,5 stephen dillane un coup de massue
quel coût
je ne sais pas encore lequel scott mf5
ça quand même ça me lasse ça peut être
demain 8 échecs suivi éventuellement le
roi g2a oui mais ce n'est pas sur quoi
les mêmes desseins que c'est pas
classique
non je pense que tu avais 5 il y aura
des choses pour lesquelles way
c'est pour ça qu'il a lui joué la dame
il allait prendre la dame kasparov 25
je ne sais pas à la cramif fait une
petite moue l'arrière dans mes
chroniques c'est un joueur maintenant on
le sait c'est qu'un joueur de poker il
est capable de n'importe quoi
capable de craquer il est capable
d'afficher n'importe quelle excitation
assure jamais tous l autre chose qu'est
ce qui se passe sur dame f5
c'est la question on ne le sait pas
encore stéphane d'un bet5
c'est ce coup là effectivement qui
mérite à elle a joué d'ailleurs kasparov
alors il a joué d'un médecin arrive en
ville stéphane stéphane superbe erisa
alors quand même très embêtant puisque
sa menace un échec du becquet sport on
s'est pris la tête il a bougé la tête
j'ai la tête et ça c'est mauvais puisque
là les noirs menace de gagner une pièce
en faisant cavalier prend fut un échec
et ça c'est pas c'est pas bon
incroyable recommandations d'ordinateur
il s'agirait d'un mythe échec et de roy
g2 ou de dames g8 échecs nos dames
j'habitais chez kenzo l'air inférieure
on va pas trop l'idée d'un mythe échec
c'est possible projet set où je dis ça
ne change pas grand-chose et la roche et
2 et maintenant engranger 2 ouais mais
il ya d'amd 5 et celle des cinq échecs
c'est ce qu'on disait en mai c'est
l'horreur on y aura toujours des échecs
partout il se garnit castorf est
vraiment phénoménal il est vraiment
incroyable garry kasparov
il semblerait ici qu'il est encore
trouver des trucs alors que nous avons
une petite visite
voilà c'est un message de notre
réalisateur comme quoi il y aurait
beaucoup de gens connectés sur internet
et ça on le savait puisque c'est un
moment fort c'est un moment de tension
extrême
que faire aigri nous allons donner
regardez ce finish éclatant vraiment
éclater en explosifs stéphane je crois
qu'on peut le dire une tension tout à
fait remarquable nous sommes pris sur
tous les fronts et rationnellement senti
mentalement techniquement et
techniquement c'est vraiment un triple
combat que nous devons mener et vladimir
kramnik y réfléchit vraiment c'est des
moments c'est des instants magiques
ici les blancs doivent choisir le bon
coup il doit finir garry kasparov
mais c'est une véritable anguilles c'est
le houdini des échecs mais on ne le
finit pas personne ne capturent garry
kasparov a apparemment il y voilà c'est
l'horreur c'est l'horreur alors qu'il
semblerait qu'il n'y ait plus de
solutions à il va être bon il va jouer
des militaires angèle n'a pas le choix
chronique 8 approché d'eux il y aura des
échecs
voilà un homme j'ai vite adam g il veut
gagner du temps je consomme j'évite
échec et va répéter les coups francs que
ça sert à rien il ya plus de contrôles
temps si on prend 10 secondes par coup
stéphane non non non c'est pas du temps
qui se cumulent ces 10 secondes par coup
qui nous ont accumulé peut-être que
cramique n'est pas au courant
enfin il veut prendre la bulle ici n'est
pas au courant de cette nouvelle cadence
si si mais sur qui le sait puisque c'est
un choix des joueurs
vraisemblablement une galerie 14 devrait
venir sur la case h6 et très vite ça va
être jamais être un match tu y vas faire
dame a chuté cheikh est après 2,8
probablement
tempo il va jouer deux matches huit
échecs je veux dire qu'emmener jamais
failli les jamais fini le kasparov le
cas sport n'est jamais finie on n'achève
pas la bête comme ça c'est une partie
que personne ne peut gagner contre eux
passent par an ça va durer très très
longtemps
c'est horrible il est hyper fight c'est
puisqu'il perd fight la c1 il se lève
voilà le pib attend les poches j'y vais
tranquille il est tranquille la même
honnêteté marine aurait entendu quelque
chose peut-être mais on a tout calculé
le dis ce que je pense qu'il aurait
entendu un bruit assez lourd heures
alors qu'il était mineur presque 30
et oui stéphane si tu continues à
compter les minutes les internautes font
penser que tu as quelque chose à faire
ce qu'on fait est là c'est l'horreur
c'est l'horreur tu vas devoir rater
cette fin de partie
et bien non puisque rappelons que tu a
rendez vous avec une jeune fille de
londres mg vite
roanne 6 chronique réfléchi kasparov a
tout vu at il tout vu
on peut se le demander car je quitte la
salle bientôt payer pour ceux qui
m'écoutent sachez que ça me casse les
oreilles
tout à fait et tu vas nous manquer
stéphane tu va beaucoup nous manquer
c'est l'horreur c'est l'horreur
la variante à l'air force et de tous les
côtés
tout à fait incroyable ça ça passe
il semblerait stéphane que ce soit une
force et non si complètement incroyable
coup de théâtre absolument spectaculaire
ce serait une nulle force et on va vous
la montrer voilà dans cette position que
la dernière chronique doit jouer dame
habite échec
kasparov va mettre le roi en six mois
j'ai 2 à munich doit jouer orange et
deux sur coup à 14 jours à dalle des
cinq échecs et là il n'y a pas le choix
il faut jouer f3
sinon c'est un échec perpétuelle en d1
oui hélas hélas il n'ya cavaliers au 5
et le pion f3 ne peut pas être défendue
incroyable complètement incroyable
kasparov s'en sort vraiment c'est tout à
fait scandaleux
c'est un vrai scandale stéphanie cette
incroyable la presse café kramnik caspar
enfin il va s'échapper
et oui pour battre kasparov
il faut se lever tôt
non mais c'est décourageant quand même
des choses comme ça stéphane s'est passé
c'est à peine croyable
c'est à peine croyable kramnik faut bien
faire des imprécisions il ya je romps h1
qui était quand même s'est apprécié
après il n'a pas joué j'ai trois villes
les joueurs us tout d'abord il est
d'abord je l'aurais à jouer quand même
pas mal de coups qui ont permis au
classement de replacer ces pièces alors
qu'il aurait dû pu être un peu plus
précis mais comme disait le proverbe
pour battre kasparov
il faut gagner dans l'ouverture dans le
milieu de jeu et dans la finale on ne
peut pas laisser un seul segment de la
partie sinon le fourgon dit non mais
vraiment cette partie stéphane je ne
sais plus quoi dire que je pense il est
imbattable
il a perdu des jeunes partis quand même
nom mais comment elle serait sortie dans
ces deux parties avec les noirs ici
c'est le nul force et on va remontrer la
variante à dos d'âne aux internautes il
faut remonter ça voilà la position à
kerviel
incroyable chronique va faire échec à
schmitt 3g 6 échecs à huit roues h6 il
faut jouer roi g28 il ya trop de menaces
d'un des cinq échecs on n'a pas le choix
tous les coups font nulle si on vient
ouvrage 3 on se fiait mater oui on ce
nom n'en est pas maintenant question
elle revient mais airfit dames et 5,0
fed avec 5 sur virage 3 / donc ici si on
vient aux f1 il revient en d1 il revient
on descendait qu'il faut jouer 3 hélas
il y a l'incroyable qui se produit
cavalier e 5 et c'est nul et sept
disques en céramique peuvent faire nul
c'est pas sûr mettra dix jours on passe
à s'il veut faire nul c'est sûr puisque
là ça commence à devenir risqué bref oui
c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchit oui il va
tarder à ma chute l'on peut faire dans
ma chute
oui comme elle peut faire d'une part et
chaque perpétuelle ici probablement
sinon rien incroyable travnik un raté
gaspard ouais là ma chouette échec ça
l'obligé
je ne crois pas s il avait mis s'en fout
en d4 c'était pas pareil je ne crois pas
qu'il ait vu quelque chose mais enfin
attention parce que c'est surprise
surprise rebondissement ce
rebondissement sata soirée ouais non
mais à roger 6 peut-être que krainik a
vu quelque chose en tout cas il ne fera
pas nul avant d'être convaincu qu'il
n'ya plus rien avoir à voir mais c'est
sûr qu'ils annulent la nulle part est
probable très très bizarrement c'est
l'horreur crâne nice a fait deux fois
qu'il allait blanc qui dominent kasparov
d'un mythe échec un échec
qu'est ce qu'il a vu la lumière rouge à
17 h sera g7 il va jouer au risque
espérant qu'un jour moi j'essaie tout si
on arrive à jouer il est confiant il est
serein
tranquille il regardera schiste sur ce
il se relève il se relève et sur
pression' une salle il a tout calculé à
part un coup droit on ne voit pas ce que
peut faire vladimir kramnik pour cette
position maladie lamal a sévi dans ces
deux cavaliers prendre ou avec échec
et ça c'est quand même une sacrée mais
c'est quand même une super menace
puisque l'aca malti c'est l'énorme
évident du mat déjà prouvé 3 d'un
problème de dmg de maths en plus rage du
web il y aura comme preuve deux communes
concernées
c'est nul parties nulles il faut que
kramnik rang face à un échec perpétuelle
c'est kasparov qui menacent et l'egypte
habituel mais c'est rami qui est obligé
de le faire maintenant c'est aux
passeports
c'est une année signale le crois pas et
le crois pas qu'on le croit pas mais là
pourtant ça paraît inéluctable
ils étaient gagnées entre amis qu'il a
raté quelque chose encore une fois et ça
c'est un petit peu énervant
kasparov et tapis là il est là en train
de regarder vladimir kramnik oui c'est
bien stéphane merci donc nous ferons
pour le résultat puisque
vraisemblablement les joueurs vont faire
nul assez rapidement maintenant et tu
dois nous quitter alors attention
prince est une tragédie véritable
tragédie
incroyable garry kasparov a une fois de
plus confirmer sa réputation de houdini
du jeu d'échecs même complètement cuit
il n'a pas perdu
garry kasparov se bat il fight et c'est
complètement incroyable ce qui s'est
produit dans cette partie tout le monde
était sûr que krainik avait gagné il
devait gagner il aurait dû gagner voilà
on voit que lesparre of là qui attend il
attend que la nuls soit conclu cette
fois-ci il semble bien que ce soit la
bonne il va s'en sortir et garry
kasparov et il montre une fois de plus
que sa grande force c'est le calcul des
ventes forcées
c'est la résistance c'est-à-dire
chronique à l'air enfin n'a plus l'air
de rien il est complètement dépité tout
simplement que dire d'autre
platini on n'a pas pu faire grand chose
dans cette partie
il aurait dû la gagner il aurait dû tout
faire c'était avait l'air facile mais
contre une bête comme garry kasparov ce
n'est jamais facile
ici il continue à chercher dans cette
position l'ordinateur ne trouve rien
garry kasparov n'a rien trouvé non plus
apparemment ce serait nul il n'y aurait
pas de solution il reste onze minutes
akram nique dans ce finish époustouflant
11 minutes + 10 secondes par coup il ne
trouve plus rien ils ne bougent plus
chronique il est complètement dépité on
va finir par croire que garry kasparov
est imbattable
on ne peut pas même complètement gagnant
même un pion de plus même une poubelle
complète pour garry kasparov
il s'en sort quand même il n'y a pas de
mystère il n'y a pas de solution krainik
approuvé une de ses faiblesses et une de
ses qualités il est très combatif ça
c'est sûr c'est bien sa grosse faiblesse
est en crise de temps où hilary kasparov
devient trop fort pour lui il est
complètement dominés dans les tailles
notes et dès qu'il a beaucoup de coups à
jouer en peu de temps
et bien il ne s'en sort pas il ne trouve
pas tout simplement
alors que quand il a beaucoup de temps
pour réfléchir et bien là sa conception
se révèle systématiquement supérieures à
celles de garry kasparov
il joue très bien vladimir kramnik mais
il lui manque quelques arguments
quelques atouts pour pouvoir triompher
de garry kasparov en tout cas là
apparemment il n'y a vraiment plus rien
à trouver cette fois ci c'est à dire sur
qui nous a déjà fait mentir plusieurs
fois vladimir mais cette fois ci
apparemment ces désespérés et oui alors
que nous alternons les planteurs kramnik
kasparov est parti dans sa loge
voilà il revient et bien c'est nul mais
ce n'a pas encore été conclue donc
stéphane un petit mot peut-être pendant
que tu es de retour
non mais voilà non mais et oui
effectivement en quatre mots stéphane a
résumé la situation
et oui il n'ya plus rien à faire pour
vladimir incroyable alors que sa pendule
tourne il lui reste neuf minutes 30
une garry kasparov et dans les coulisses
il va vraisemblablement ici répéter les
coups si vous avez la position sur votre
plate à droite il va rejouer damache 8
et là nul sera conclu sous un tonerre
d'applaudissements garry kasparov s'est
remis à sa table il attend la
proposition de nul ici il est persuadé
qu'il s'en est sorti et on ne voit pas
comment chronique pourrait trouver des
chances maintenant à ce stade de la
partie il y a trop de menaces autour de
son roi c'est tout simplement terminer
incroyable performance incroyable
performance de garry kasparov incroyable
performance également de vladimir
kramnik superbe partie entre un joueur
de toute évidence moins fort garry
kasparov mais beaucoup plus combatifs
vraiment ni harry kasparov n'est pas
mort il faut le dire il est c'est vrai
dominé par krainik au niveau de la
conception au niveau des ouvertures au
niveau 2 au niveau du jeu mais quand
même il est beaucoup plus résistant
beaucoup plus teigneux il est beaucoup
plus sportive probablement s'éteindre un
vrai joueur de compétition il ne l'a
jamais la faire il ne l'a jamais le
morceau et il saisit toutes les
ressources
c'est tout à fait incroyable damache 8
nuls voilà ça y est c'est terminé c'est
terminé c'est tout à fait incroyable
garry kasparov sauve la nul sauve la
nulle dans cette partie c'est miraculeux
alors que l'arbitré va stopper les
pendules va mettre les rois ensemble
c'est nul complètement incroyable hein
ce qui s'est passé dans cette partie
garry kasparov est content il est
heureux il s'en est sorti c'est
miraculeux vladimir kramnik lui dis
attention avec son doigt
je t'ai raté mais je ne raterai pas deux
fois et donc évidemment ne nous quitte
et pas puisque la conférence de presse
va arriver les joueurs vont quitter la
scène mais pas pour longtemps puisque
ils reviendront armée de micro pour
répondre aux questions des journalistes
il n'y a aucun doute que dans cette
partie kramnik été gagnant voilà les
joueurs signent la feuille c'est le
rituel c'est terminé garry kasparov a
arraché la nul avec une position
complètement perdante score après six
parties trois et demi deux ans et demi
pour vladimir kramnik donc une victoire
à zéro 5 parties nulles voilà c'est
vladimir kramnik qui mène le match
toujours et très bientôt à venir la
conférence de presse c'est qu'ils
arrivent avec les joueurs qui vont
revenir
voilà on voi arbitre qui remet les
pièces en place superbe partie superbes
parties une partie qui aura duré donc en
tout et pour tout 6h25
6h25 un peu plus même presque six heures
et demie oui d'ailleurs plus de six
heures et demie 18h45 alors a duré sept
parties vraiment stupéfiant 18h45 de jeu
6h45 où les joueurs ont combattu ou
chronique était beaucoup mieux depuis le
40e coup il a trouvé une conception
d'enfer il avait une position largement
meilleur mais n'a pas réussi à s'imposer
suite à une défense complètement
spectaculaire de garry kasparov tout à
fait hallucinant hallucinant ce qui
s'est produit alors que les joueurs vont
bientôt être rappelés sur scène pour la
conférence de presse et là ça va être du
très beau spectacle de très bonnes
questions probablement des journalistes
sur motivés devant un tel combat
devant une telle partie c'était sans
aucun doute la plus belle partie du
match évidemment je vous invite à revoir
les résumés qui vont suivre
d'abord en anglais ensuite en français
ça sera tout de suite après la
conférence de presse disons trois ou
quatre minutes après voilà on voit les
micros qui arrive sur scène micro pour
que les joueurs puissent répondre avec
voilà on branche le micro donc
évidemment il y aura les résumés après
la conférence de presse
et si vous avez envie de nous quitter
pour ce soir à bien les résumés seront
disponibles dès demain vous pourrez
regarder soit en français soit en
anglais et vous pourrez même revoir
cette conférence de presse qui va être
archivé sur canal web et sur brink games
sur les sites partenaires de cet
événement enfin one game c'est carrément
l'organisateur canal web est un
partenaire le partenaire média est ici
nous attendons nos deux champions qui
sont épuisés par le combat donc qui ne
devrait pas être trop prolixe puisque
effectivement c'était une très très
grosse partie qu'ils nous ont fait alala
bitrate ans les joueurs tout se met en
place et ils vont bientôt revenir sous
une tonne d'applaudissements halal
arbitre va aller les chercher
tout à fait et les voilà je vous laisse
donc avec nos joueurs vladimir kramnik
et garry kasparov superbe partie trois
et demi deux ans et demi en faveur du
challenger après sept nuls de combat
dans la 6ème monde
c'est pourquoi des mines
à gaspé que des gay games week
à